you know chris got hit
you know in the knees yesterday which is
a play that i think they ought to
take out of the game of football uh from
a receiver standpoint you know i've kind
of
talked to the pa about it for a while
about
you know and i'd like to speak to the
rules competition committee at some
point this offseason to i've seen that
hit too many times where a defenseless
pass catcher is in the process of
catching a ball then he's hit by the
defender and you know a lot of the
defenders will say well we can't hit him
in the head anymore
well the point is you can't hit anyone
in the head anymore and you can't hit
any one of these anymore except for
receivers because you can still hit them
in the knees which doesn't make any
sense to me
um you can't hit a defensive lineman in
the knees
you can't hit a punter in the knees you
can't hit a quarterback at the knees you
can't hit a db in the knees
except we're somehow allowing
hits on defenseless receivers in these
so
now it needs to be addressed and it
needs to be really thought out it really
impacts guys careers and and chris you
know i know he'll overcome it
so it's a tough rehab but you know you
you tear your acl that's that's a
lifelong injury
you know and i'm sure almost every pass
catcher in the nfl would prefer
hit to the head over a hit to the knees
i certainly would i take that you know
million out of a million
it's it's it's amazing man tom said
basically everything that i said the
other day and
my whole thing was protect your brother
you know what i'm saying protect your
brother you got to understand i like pj
with excuse me i like pj williams when i
called him out it wasn't because the hit
was dirty necessarily dirty okay it was
a clean hit by nfl standards but to me
it was a dirty hit because pj williams
he's a very smart guy he's played all
the positions in the secondary he's a
very versatile guy so he's a very smart
guy when he hit godwin on the knees he
immediately got up and celebrated he
didn't so he intentionally he wanted to
hit him at his knees and all i'm saying
is look man we're all trying to make a
living why would you hit him up there
you asked any player in any sport female
male in any sport would you rather get
hit in the knee or would you rather get
hit in the shoulder they're gonna 100
out of 100 times they're going to say
hit me up in the upper body because now
i have a chance to get up and walk away
i get a chance to get up and literally
walk away but when you go at somebody's
knees and tom is 100 spot on you don't
go at their knees because we are
brothers i can't take away your
opportunity to make millions and
millions of dollars check this out chris
godwin signed a one-year 15 million
dollar deal one year 15 million dollar
deal he could have he could have gone
many other places got 50 60 million
dollars or 40 million dollars guaranteed
and and secured the bag he sacrificed
for that situation and now all of a
sudden what team is going to go and pay
chris godwin four years 60 million and
guarantee 40 million because he's coming
off an ac injury so what he's got to do
he's got to sign another one-year deal
go through an entire season
17 weeks 18 weeks plus playoffs and see
if he can stay healthy to go get his
money so that's why i tell players all
the time these teams have money they're
very very wealthy you got to secure the
bag always get your money don't
sacrifice for anybody
well i completely agree so let me start
there and and something that stood out
from what tom said was that receiver is
the only position that we let hits like
this occur through that resonated with
me right you can't do it to a
quarterback that's completely out of the
game you can't do it to a defensive line
that's complete out of game can't do it
to an offensive line that's completely
out of the game so you can't do it to
anybody else now how the hell are you
going to look at me and say that a
receiver can't do it to a kicker after a
kick how the hell are you going to look
at me and say that a receiver who's
catching the ball with his head turned
running full speed and getting hit from
a place that he doesn't even know is
coming that that could be a legal hit it
just makes no sense and to hear tom go a
million out of a million i would take
the high hit over the low hit well why
aren't we talking to the players then
before we're making this rule and this
has been one that hasn't made sense to
me for a long time we've seen gronk take
these shots i thought gronk after the
first hit we both thought this rod that
he was looking a little tentative out
there after that massive shot
let's be clear i mean this was a game
where new orleans came in and from the
opening whistle was the more physical
team they were physically just pushing
around tampa in their own stadium in
every single way but i will say that i
thought that pj williams shot low it
changed gronk it changed some of those
weapons i just thought it looked like
tampa was playing tentative from then on
out
absolutely it was spot on i mean you
look at gronk gronk like gronk when
you've had injuries to your knee
you think about that you say oh my god i
don't want to go across the middle no
send me out to the you know to the
sideline i don't want to come across the
middle it changed the very nature of the
game because you saw even um tyler
johnson he was in the game he went
across the middle he's peeking and
looking and i'm like it just me you and
i we talked about it completely changed
the you know the nature of the game
i do think that they will go back and
look at that as we take a look at some
of gronk's plays and he just always
looks sort of half speed and anytime
they would take a close shot of his face
he just looked nervous dropping balls
he's looking he's looking up for the hit
before he's even making the catch and he
had the biggest drop of the night on
that deep one late in the game where he
just never even saw it he was what brady
put the perfect throw down the sideline
and he just didn't look up to see it
right there there it was
yeah fournette told me that rob
gronkowski is the guy that brings all
the energy to this team and he didn't
have any energy we're looking at like
rob is normally a lot more you know
active and excited he just kind of out
there he looked tired he looked like he
was out of shape i'm like what's going
on with rob gronkowski but that hit
really set the tone
and it wasn't the only hit right i mean
i i can remember a handful of other big
hits even the one where fournette got
spun around i mean he they spun him in a
full 360. and fournette leaves the game
i mean it they came in there and they
just pushed him around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports